well that's something that's certainly
not going to change overnight sabino ohm
joins us now an economist and eu
consultant or european policy officer
for the farm welfare group
fee
will it ever be the case that the food
sector is not interested in making
profits the consumers don't want the
best deal
well of course they have to make profits
because if not our enterprise will fail
and the same as goes for agriculture of
course the farmers have to make money
because if not they can't live and
nourish their families by it so
we do not want to destroy farming in
germany we do not ask them to do the
impossible
but we offer also solutions and what
your main concern is that these groups
or producers could just up and leave
well
the producers could actually
do some more in order to develop
alternatives they could improve animal
welfare without having to
mistreat animals or destroy them as
we've seen in there give us give us an
example
well
an example that concerns the whole
sector actually would be cage eggs hens
were used to be kept in battery cages
and then in larger cages which are no
better and we convinced supermarkets to
take them off the shelves there's no
fresh eggs from caged hands anymore and
this is because it's an immoral product
so the consumer doesn't have this choice
anymore
of course we cannot take out all
broilers or meat from poultry or
all eggs for that matter out of shelves
we do need some other alternatives there
but but what needs to be done now as far
as chickens go male chickens well
there's two ways for once the
sector and ecological farming the
biosector could use dual purpose chicks
where the males are used for raising for
meat and the hands are used for layer
hens for laying eggs
and then the industry in itself could
ferment these research which is almost
at um
at the point of being able to sex eggs
before the hatchlings actually come to
life to work out if it's a male or
female exactly um so then these eggs
could be exported to countries where
such eggs are still eaten or destroyed
but then you wouldn't have to kill
chicks in the film we didn't see what is
actually being done to a lot of these
chicks they're put into a shredder
they're shredded alive without any
anesthesia and not all of them are
killed by co2 i said what about
consumers and the role they play in all
of this because if we take a look at the
figures as far as conventional methods
go and organic food processing well over
one and a half million tons of chicken
is mass produced in germany only 13 and
a half thousand tons is processed
organically there's an even bigger
discrepancy if we take a look at pork
more than five and a half million tons
is made by conventional methods only 23
000 is organic why the huge difference
well because the farming methods are
basically very very diff different the
organic farmers respect the environment
and the animals needs
which is not done in conventional
farming to the extent needed actually so
the price difference is huge but by
raising standards in conventional
farming
this gap could be closed a little bit
and then
the sector of
organic could be expanded to a larger
degree as well by supporting it better
with better science also sabino um thank
you very much for the analysis thank you